dans les yvelines à droite progresse à
l'issue de ce premier tour des
municipales plusieurs villes ont déjà
basculé c'est le cas de poissy où le
conseiller général karl olive
l'emportent avec plus de 62% face au
socialiste frédérik bernard ou encore de
bois d'arcy ou philippe benassaya
s'impose avec 57% même si pour le député
ps de la circonscription le maire
sortant claude juillet a surtout mené la
campagne de trop à 80 printemps passé
moi je veux pas rentrer dans les
problèmes de personne mais je pose une
question est il raisonnable qu'on soit
de droite ou de gauche est il
raisonnable de se présenter pour un
quatrième mandat successif à 80 ans est
il raisonnable et bien les artisans ont
répondu à cette question
le parti socialiste qui lors de ce
premier tour n'a pas réussi non plus à
renforcer son opposition dont
l'agglomération de saint quentin les
listes menées par vivien gasc à montigny
le bretonneux ou michel beso à elancourt
sont sévèrement battu donc le
département des yvelines
l'étiquette ump
a plutôt porté bonheur à fait aux listes
ump
il a une vraie touche et de la droite
donc il faut là il faut quand même sur
le département l'élan de la droite est
extraordinairement fort et nous voulons
le concrétiser
le rassemblement de la droite et du
centre
on retiendra cependant que la commune de
magny les hameaux ne connaîtra pas
l'alternance malgré les efforts de rohr
berger pourtant soutenu par de nombreux
poids lourds de l'ump dans les autres
communes du département on retiendra
aussi pour l'ump quelques victoires
nettes dans ses bastions de versailles
avec françois de mazières ou encore du
chesnay avec philippe brillault à
rambouillet un second tour sera
nécessaire pour désigner le successeur
de gérard larcher je suis très serein
sur rambouillet je suis absolument
persuadé que les résultats seront
excellents puisque c'est dans la
continuité de ce qu'a fait gérable
et de ce qu'a fait jean frédéric poisson
aussi